good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm gonna
try an experiment today I had to make a
video today what should I make it about
velociraptors I'm into it okay the
velociraptors so the Velociraptor was
not a famous dinosaur until Michael
Crichton's 1990 novel Jurassic Park in
that book in the subsequent Steven
Spielberg movie a Velociraptor skeleton
is excavated in Montana and they're
these like terrifying creatures they're
smart and almost people sighs and they
got those weird reptilian scales and
they hunt in packs
taking down dinos and people alike but
even if you haven't seen Jurassic Park
and God knows Henry hasn't you're still
familiar with like the terror of the
Velociraptor right like Toronto named
its NBA team after the Raptors because
they're just y'all you want to stay away
from them they're gonna beat you at
basketball yeah except one the
Velociraptor never actually lived in
Montana it lived in Mongolia in China
two velociraptors were not scaly they
were feathered three they probably
didn't hunt in packs for they could not
have hung out in Jurassic Park because
they lived 75 million years ago in the
Late Cretaceous period and five they
were not human sized killing machines
they were like long-tailed turkeys in
short Hank the Toronto Raptors are named
after a Mongolian creature that probably
looked like this adult velociraptors way
too less than the average three-year-old
human and although their name means
Swift thief's in fact they were probably
quite slow because they were walking on
short little turkey legs off-topic but
at the State Fair turkey legs are just
so delicious I wonder if Velociraptor
legs are good you may have noticed that
in real life there is one animal species
that's truly terrifying and it's us we
would have posed a far greater threat to
velociraptors than they would have posed
to us anyway the velociraptors in
Jurassic Park are based off of a larger
American cousin called Deinonychus but
they called them velociraptors because
that's a much cooler name Hank and that
actually happens a lot in the world of
dinosaurs psychic when we were kids the
coolest dinosaur in the world was the
brontosaurus which means Thunder lizard
but Hank it turns out that brontosaurus
isn't even a thing it's just an
Apatosaurus which means deceptive lizard
which isn't nearly as cool I don't want
my gigantic lizards to bring the lies I
want them to bring the Thunder
also as Henry will happily point out to
you Apatosaurus isn't even that big
certainly not compared to Diplodocus so
why did velociraptors have feathers well
they
the bird-like dromaeosaurus had feathers
and some which could probably actually
fly the velociraptors couldn't fly they
may have used their feathers to like
attract mates but probably it's just an
evolutionary leftover the way that blind
mole rats still have eyes and humpback
whales have vestigial hind legs
but now that I've disappointed you about
dying you the truth about velociraptors
I'm going to tell you two awesome things
about them first they could jump like 10
feet high vertical secondly they had
these retractable sickle-shaped clause
in their hind legs that they used to
like stab their prey and we know they
could kill these somewhat larger
although not as large as you would
expect Protoceratops we know this partly
because there's a fossil of a
velociraptor and a Protoceratops locked
in combat and then while they were
fighting a sandstorm came and drowned
them in sand Hank the pleasure of having
a dinosaur obsessed child is that you
realize both how much we know and how
much we don't know about the distant
past of life on earth
like Hank the reason that Michael
Crichton's velociraptors were
featherless is that we didn't know for
sure until 2007 that velociraptors were
feathered because that's when scientists
discovered quill knobs on one of their
forearms there are a lot of cool things
about dinosaurs Hank but the coolest
thing is that a hundred million years
later we're still learning thanks to
Henry for the video topic Hank I'll see
you on Friday